c'est un laboratoire anti sécheresse à
ciel ouvert il y a deux ans et demi cet
agriculteur implanté entre ces parcelles
des haies d'arbres plus résistants au
réchauffement climatique
voici un orme lutèce normes hybride qui
est adapté au sol ses chants ensuite ici
on a un chêne vert qui n'est pas
vraiment de la région mais qui est du
sud de la france qui lui poussent
naturellement dans une région plus et
chante qu'ici et puis une essence qui
pousse aussi localement qui te pousse
déjà sur les sols ses chances et le
genévrier qui lui al'avantage de garder
ses aiguilles l'hiver pour ce producteur
laitier
c est sont de véritables atouts sa
puisent l'eau en profondeur dans le sol
ça ramène certaine humilité
environnantes ça fait de l'ombre animaux
ça peut servir d'arbres fourrage et pour
certaines espèces comme norme
bonjour j'aurais fait une système
agroforestier qui s'intègre dans un
programme de replantation mené par le
parc régional de braine et bah tu vois
ça pousse après deux années de
sécheresse 2018-2019 qu'un petit coup en
juin bon bah ça souffre un petit peu
mais sa peau c'est pas trop mal ça n'a
même pas été arrosé des essais
concluants à rebours des arrachages de
est mené pendant plusieurs décennies
pendant des années les politiques
agricoles encourageait toujours plus de
surface est considéré comme des espaces
et des milieux non productifs et non
agricoles et donc les agriculteurs ont
été encouragés simplement à les arracher
une politique contraire aux principes
d'agroforesterie de thierry pavageau ici
ce sont plus de 900 arbres qui ont été
plantés